so a whole bunch of these Republicans  who have a long history of voting  against disaster relief when there's  like a hurricane or something in a  different state now they all want it in  Florida and listen I think they should  get it I really do you shouldn't punish  the people of Florida because their  elected officials are horrible people  but can we just stop with this nonsense  we need Federal disaster relief if you  are in Oklahoma and you vote no for  superstorm Sandy relief but then you  want Oklahoma tornado relief you're a  hypocrite and I know they say well there  was pork uh no no  disaster relief it's okay just be  consistent you don't have to be  hypocrites